S
NETWORK. ALL RIGHT, JUST IN TO
CNN, THE HISTORIC DEFAMATION
CASE AGAINST FAX NEWS IS HEADING
TO A HIGH STAKES JURY TRIAL NEXT
MONTH. WE'RE LEARNING MORE ABOUT
THE JUDGE'S RULING TODAY AND
WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE DOMINION
VOTING SYSTEMS $1.6 BILLION
LAWSUIT AGAINST FOX. LET'S BRING
IN OUR SENIOR MEDIA REPORTER
OLIVER DARCY AND CNN LEGAL
ANALYST NORM EISEN. OLIVER THE
JUDGE JUST RULED AGAINST SOME OF
FOX NEWS IS KEY DEFENSES. TELL
US MORE ABOUT THAT. THAT'S
RIGHT, WOLF. THIS IS REALLY NOT
A GOOD RULING. IF YOUR FOX NEWS
NOT ONLY DID THE JUDGE NOT GRANT
FOX NEWS, THEY'RE ASKED, WHICH
WAS THAT THEY DECLARED BE
DECLARED THE WINNER AHEAD OF A
TRIAL, BUT THE JUDGE IS ACTUALLY
DISMANTLING SOME OF FOX'S LEGAL
ARGUMENTS IN THIS 130 PAGE
DECISION. ONE OF THOSE ARGUMENTS
IS THAT WHAT WAS BROADCAST ON
FOX WAS OPINION, SO IT'S
PROTECTED UNDER THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. THE JUDGE SAYS. NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, HE SAYS, HE
WRITES IN HIS OPINION. HE SAYS.
THE CONTACT SUPPORTS THE
POSITION THAT THE STATEMENTS
WERE NOT PURE OPINION WHERE THEY
WERE MADE BY NEWSCASTERS HOLDING
THEMSELVES OUT TO BE SOURCES OF
ACCURATE INFORMATION. HE RULES
THAT THERE WERE FACTUAL
ASSERTIONS OR MIXED OPINION,
WHICH IS A REAL BLOW TO FOX
NEWS, BUT HE EVEN TAKES IT A
STEP FURTHER WOLF AND HE SAYS
THAT EVEN IF THIS WAS OPINION,
IT'S STILL NOT PROTECTED UNDER
THE FIRST AMENDMENT BECAUSE
THERE WAS AN ALLEGATION OF A
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY AGAINST
DOMINION, HE WRITES IN HIS
OPINION, HE SAYS, THE STATEMENT
ALSO SEEM TO CHARGE DOMINION
WITH THE SERIOUS CRIME OF
ELECTION FRAUD, ACCUSATIONS OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY, EVEN IN THE
FORM OF OPINION ARE NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED. AND
I SHOULD NOTE HERE WOLF THAT FOX
HAS FOUGHT TOOTH AND NAIL OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS TO
AVOID THIS MOMENT TO AVOID GOING
TO TRIAL. A JUDGE NOW SAYING
THAT THIS WILL GO TO TRIAL IN
MID APRIL. VERY INTERESTING. THE
JUDGE ALSO SAID NORM THAT IT WAS
QUOTE CRYSTAL CLEAR, CRYSTAL
CLEAR THAT NONE OF THE
STATEMENTS FOX AIRED ABOUT
DOMINION WERE TRUE. DOES THAT
GIVE DOMINION THE UPPER HAND
GOING INTO THIS UPCOMING TRIAL?
I THINK IT DOES. WOLF THEY ARE
NO LONGER GOING TO HAVE TO ARGUE
OR PROVE TO THE JURY THAT FOX
WAS PUBLISHING FALSE STATEMENTS
ABOUT THEM. INSTEAD THE JURY IS
GOING TO BE INSTRUCTED THAT THEY
WERE FALSE AND TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF HOW STRONGLY THE JUDGE
FELT ABOUT IT, WOLF. I DON'T
KNOW WHEN I'VE SEEN THIS IN A
JUDICIAL OPINION, HE PUT CRYSTAL
IN ALL CAPS IN ITALICS AND IN
BOLD BASICALLY SHOUTED IT. THAT
PORTION OF THE OPINION IS REALLY
HISTORIC. TOGETHER WITH THE
JANUARY 6TH. COMMITTEE REPORT OR
THAT SPECIAL GRAND JURY REPORT
IN GEORGIA, BOTH ALSO SAYING
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
CLAI